all right I'm gonna eat it I just can't
help myself mm-hmm
I think I'm gonna get a sugar high we
recently just bought a house together we
had our first holiday last year we've
been together for 13 years now you seem
like it's been longer than that we both
just really were ready to stop renting
it was a lot invested into this can we
make a model of our house out of
gingerbread I'm not saying it's gonna
come out perfect but you know we can try
you definitely have to reset it up honey
cuz I literally am so bad sorry so we're
gonna start first what are you doing I
don't know actually I don't know what
I'm doing honey
I don't really see where the front door
is I'm definitely more of a demolition
guys and builder oh boy my man cave I
feel like he made the garage bigger in
this this needs to stick out a little
further
yeah I'm saying nope let's do it family
photo the front door is the kitchen and
this is the garage Shh I live here then
I'd eat the walls I'm gonna make our bed
because it's really big and it's my
favorite part of our bedroom the bed's
be made first and then the fridge is
right after that I don't know if this
looks like our house is home yeah I
totally see it you know are you kidding
it's exactly happy wife is a happy life
Oh Mauro your left hand look at how
talented your bowtie test is right
pretty solid fell down you just push it
back in there we just put a roof on it
now please wait where's this spot oh oh
nice
look at me this is a lot of fun
should we sprinkle it up or what don't
you like that
this is really cute it is thank you
I picked a winner that's you this is me
[Music]
you please go get me a glass of wine
yeah perfect
well if Ray would had an easier time
buying this one and we had some missteps
but all in all it's a solid home
it's our
[Music]